-Our next guest is a comedian
and actor you know from
his work on shows such as
"The Middle,"
"Saturday Night Live,"
and movies like
"A Night at the Roxbury."
He stars in "Famous,"
which is in theaters
and available on demand
December 10th.
Please welcome to the show
our very good friend
Chris Kattan, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Christopher!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How are you, buddy?
-I'm great. How are you?
-It's so great to have you
not just in New York,
but back in the building
where we met.
You flew from L.A. yesterday?
-I did.
-How was your flight? Good?
-Oh, thank you for asking.
-Good. That was the thing
about our friendship.
We always checked in about how
each other's flights went.
-Yeah, I did that last week.
I said, "How was your flight?",
and you weren't even on one.
-Yeah.
-But I like the care that you
took to just check to make sure.
-I'm very caring about you
and your flights.
-Always, from the day we met.
-Always.
-How's the miles, the mileage?
-Oh, my miles -- it's a little
down because of COVID.
-Ooh! Ooh, yeah.
-I've lost a bit of my status
on some of the majors.
-I also got your message about
you asking me about my miles,
and I never answered.
-Okay. How are your miles?
-Not so good, as well.
-Okay.
How was your flight yesterday?
-It was good.
Thanks again for asking.
It was good.
I sat next to, interestingly
enough, Helen Hunt,
but I didn't know it was her,
because we have masks on.
So we had no idea.
She had no idea it was me,
and I had no idea it was her.
But I met her years ago,
'cause she was friends with
my dad, and my dad was one of
the founders of The Groundlings.
You know The Groundlings.
-Yeah, of course.
So did you figure out on the way
off the plane that you were?
-It was 10 minutes before,
and I was kind of like,
"Why didn't you say anything?"
And she was also like,
-Yeah.
-And we got into a little tiff.
-Oh. So it ended badly?
-No, there was a minute before
I got off the plane
that it ended up being okay.
Because I said,
"The last time I saw you,
you were hosting 'SNL.'"
And she hosted
'cause she was pushing, I think,
"As Good as It Gets"
at that time.
-Yeah.
-And Hanson was
the musical guest.
I don't know if
you remember Hanson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, don't get --
They're not here, so...
Maybe one member is.
Why would --
They're like, "Yay!"
Anyway...
But Hanson was the guest.
-You gestured to them.
You elicited that response.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well...
-That's not for you!
[ Laughter ]
-I got so excited.
Every time somebody
says "Hanson," I get excited.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, so, anyway,
one of the Hanson brothers?
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
And -- Was running
up and down the hallway,
and she said,
"Stop running, Hanson!",
'cause she didn't know
the name of that Hanson.
-Yeah. You know what's
interesting about seeing
Helen Hunt on an airplane?
-Yes.
-Maybe one of the stars of
one of the most famous
"SNL" airplane sketches
of all time.
-Is?
-"Buh-bye."
-Oh, right, "Buh-bye."
Yes, with David Spade.
Very good.
-Maybe you'll see it later.
Not as popular as Hanson,
but it has some --
-You'd think the meter is,
you know...
-I owe you a lot.
I owe you my world.
-Oh, no, yes, your world.
-Yeah. I mean this with
all sincerity.
You know this, obviously.
I think some people
might know this.
I met my wife at your wedding.
-Yes, you did.
-And now we got
three kids, and --
-And it's all 'cause of me!
-It's all thanks to you
inviting me to your wedding.
I did not know my wife,
and I met her there.
-Right. And I like that you
tell that story to people.
However,
I'm not married anymore.
-No.
-So if you can not put a period
after the wedding part
and just say -- and conclude,
"I met my wife at Chris Kattan's
wedding, however..."
-Oh. You want me to make sure
that's in there, as well.
-That I'm not married anymore.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Well, just 'cause that's true.
-Yeah.
-I can make sure
I get that in there, as well.
-If you don't mind.
-Yeah.
-But we have communication
about airplanes,
so I'll probably
get that message.
-I feel like we're
the legacy of your wedding now.
We have to -- you know...
-You are.
-Yeah.
-Can I say your wife's name?
-No, you can't. I'm sorry.
-I'm gonna get in trouble?
-We've been together for
13 years,
but we are keeping her
name under wraps.
-Her name quiet.
Yeah, I saw that.
I went on Instagram like,
"Wait a second.
It's blocked."
-If you just don't mind saying
"Seth Meyers' wife --
lady -- wife lady."
-Wife lady.
-Yeah.
-That's weird.
Remember the good old days,
when we used to say "lady wife"?
-Yeah. Can't say that anymore.
-Not anymore.
-Yeah, Alexi.
-Yes, Alexi, lovely lady.
You met at my wedding,
which didn't go too far.
-You know what?
It didn't go too far.
-But that's okay.
-No, it's fine.
Yeah, of course.
-Yeah.
-But I do want to point out,
'cause now that
you've opened the doors that
I'm allowed to say
that you're not married anymore,
we went out for our
year anniversary of dating,
Alexi and I,
and you were already divorced.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And I say that
because you were --
-Well, you say that
'cause that was true.
-That was true, but, also,
you were at the restaurant
with a different person.
-With a person.
-Yeah.
-That's how you found out.
-And you walked over to
the table and you said,
"What are you guys doing?"
And Alexi said,
"It's our one-year anniversary,
and you went like this,
"Oh, right!"
-Is that how I sound?
-No, that night,
you sounded like that.
-If that's how I sound
when you tell that story
about meeting your wife
at my wedding --
"Chris said, 'Oh, right!'" --
then please don't
ever acknowledge
that you met your wife
at my wedding.
-Okay, you came over,
and were like, "How wonderful."
-Thank you. That's much better.
That I like.
-You were telling me backstage
your mom was very concerned.
She didn't know
we have that great bit
about how we talk about
airline miles.
She was helping you
come up with bits,
things to talk about
on the talk show.
-Right, 'cause I was coming on
the show, which I am now.
-Yeah.
-And --
[ Light laughter ]
Thanks. And I was like,
"Mom, I don't know what to say.
I'm a little nervous.
You know, I don't know
what kind of stories to tell."
And she looked up online
and said,
"Well, here's something
interesting.
Viagra cures Alzheimer's."
-Hmm.
-And I said, "Mom, I don't think
that's an appropriate story
to bring up or acknowledge,
but I think the fact that
you said that is what's funny."
-Yeah.
-That's a funny story.
-Yeah, right.
-That she brought that up.
-So there you go.
She gave you --
-But!
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
-Do you have more on it?
Do you have, like,
the underlying science?
-No.
-She didn't give you any?
Also, I like that she said,
"Here's a good story," and then
she just gave you a fact.
-I know. And then that was it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Not really.
Do you have any --
So, nothing else to share?
-Oh, yes, I do have
a big announcement.
-Okay.
Bigger than Viagra-Alzheimer's?
-Oh, this is very -- What?
Anyway...
But, yes, that Kim Kardashian
and Pete Davidson and I
are now going out.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is big.
-It's a big deal.
-You got back in the game.
-Yeah, I got back in the game
in a big way.
But we may break up tomorrow.
-Oh, okay.
-We don't know
what's gonna happen.
-We'll just check in as we go?
-Yeah, we'll just check in.
-Alright, great.
I want to talk more
about the movie.
We're gonna be right back
with Chris Kattan.